hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga my name is liam and what are
your thoughts on coriander me personally
i quite like it but today we're here to
examine the age-old question of who
would win the fighting three
non-wielding mutant ant monsters or one
times clown boy it's not quite as simple
to determine as you may think and in the
interest of fairness today's examination
is not going to be whether hisoka could
defeat all of the royal guard no no he
would get artillery destroyed although
to be fair he'd probably die in bliss
whilst doing so with his a raging clown
unit but to make this video well worth
making we're going to be asking whether
hisoka can defeat any of the royal guard
one on one and i know there are going to
be some oh they're going to be a lot of
strong opinions on this but don't worry
because this video is not just going to
be the opinion of a dude in a room it
will in fact involve the opinions of
thousands of dudes in thousands of rooms
because i put up a channel white poll
asking for your opinion on the mata
which we will be consulting regularly
throughout the video what i'll also say
is don't underestimate hisoka of every
character in hunter hunter he is the one
who is always most likely to surprise
you but it's all going to begin with a
quick round of pentagon a very simple
minigame the rules of which are as
follows gone for reasons has made
another stupid nen vow which has
transformed him into a rudimentary shape
and it's going to be your job to guess
which shape that is should you guess
incorrectly then your punishment will be
to form a nen vowel by subscribing to
the new world review which will also
result in consistent injections of
hunter-based culture administered
directly into your youtube feed and if
you are correct then you shall receive a
gold star on your hunter license but
which gone shape will it be shape one
two or the third one make your choice
now and we shall reveal the answer in
three two one and bam it was the square
so if you guessed incorrectly then you
know the thing to do and please do say
hi in the comments below if you are a
new member of our association welcome
all right let's clarify some stuff i'll
admit that this may be a bit of an
uphill battle for our classy clown on
almost every front because even
one-on-one the royal guard and eye on
insurmountable opponents which also has
the result of granting hisoka an ion
insurmountable erection but to make
things as fair as possible we will be
using post mortem hisoka our most recent
incarnation following his battle with
crollo in heaven's arena and if you're
not aware of his new capabilities
essentially he can now regenerate lost
body parts by crafting them with bungee
gum and he can even use texture surprise
to make them look real and we're just
not non god what let's try that again
and he can also use texture surprise to
make them look real and non-gummy but
it's not just about strict regeneration
because these new body parts end up
being superior in every way to hisoka's
old fleshy vessel because all of his
prosthetics now wield the properties of
both rubber and gum giving hisoka a
whole new world of versatility and sheer
trickery to deal with but and this this
is the most important part after having
engaged in post-mortem then hisoka is
now just plain stronger his aura has
been significantly boosted and the
mental achievement of essentially having
conquered death plays a large factor as
well due to that whole thing when nen is
intrinsically linked to mentality and
desire the stronger the desire the
higher the output which also applies to
our royal guard one of the heavily
underrated reasons why they're so
powerful is because of their primal need
to protect the king which means that
even though their theoretical of
knowledge of nen contains massive gaps
perhaps chasms maybe even full on black
holes they can still wield aura to an
above world-class standard through raw
instinct and desire alone meanwhile
hisoka's greatest advantage going into
this context is his knowledge of the art
form to the best of our knowledge he has
no formal training but hisoka is a
student of the hard streets of nen he's
well and truly up there with the likes
of karapika and crollo which is great
because if he wasn't then the video
would end probably about now
but he isn't and it's not so instead of
ending let's beginning and hisoka's
first ant based opponent will be mentho
the yupi who i think is a great
candidate to start with because he is a
pretty simple guy he has lots of power
coupled with minimal brain function and
on paper he's a pretty great opponent
for someone like hisoka to take on
however something we do need to note
about up is that he is one of if not the
only rare chimera and who doesn't
contain a single shred of human dna up
was conjured into existence via the
consumption of magical beasts so while
he may be a bit dim when it comes to
human communication and customs this
lack of humanity gives him a tremendous
advantage in combat because he gets to
abandon his mind and let instinct take
the wheel and that worked really well
for goku in a series that is not hunter
hunter so let's come up with a better
example actually killua's godspeed is a
good example of raw instinct taking over
killua basically programs his nan to
bypass the nervous system and respond to
any stimuli with well godspeed and while
yupi's nature is obviously inferior to
this particular ability that's the way
you need to think about him he isn't
bound by human thinking so he's able to
act much quicker than those who take
even a fraction of a second longer to
consider implementing some sort of
strategy now with that said that also
leaves up quite vulnerable to someone
like hisoka because while his movements
will take comparatively longer to
complete humans generally tend to
outplay the primal instincts of animals
and a character like hisoka is honestly
yupi's worst nightmare because
forgetting whether or not he can win for
a second hisoka would just be
phenomenally frustrating for yupi to
deal with yupi has never had to deal
with a genius level nen combatant in
full force the closest he would have
come would be against moral who was
missing his pipe at the time and let's
be real even if he had it izora was far
too depleted by that point to be any
real threat and very problematically we
can't rely on yupi getting in a lucky
hit for victory either because let's say
that a tentacle or even tentacles hit
hisokur and manages to take off an arm
or something well in that case hisoka
just regenerates a more powerful and
much more annoying arm to take its place
but again on the flip side of that yupi
has pretty much the same advantage
because even if hisoka can pull some
bungee gum shenanigan ray to disable
parts of up well he can just morph his
body to however he needs it to be grow
extra arms legs wings eyes maybe even
heads so we end up with two competitors
who who effectively can't hurt each
other i mean one can hurt the other
significantly more i suppose and i think
that the association has the right idea
with this matchup because when this was
put to a poll up came out on top with
over 57 of the vote but hisoka did come
a lot closer than i thought he might
taking 33 percent and even nine percent
of voters thinking that this would end
in a tie that or being too lazy to think
about who would win the problem is the
fight does become a stalemate for quite
some time which means that it turns into
a battle of pure attrition and in that
scenario i just don't see a path to
victory for hisoka yupi is just better
built for a contest of endurance because
even in a post-mortem world yupi's aura
quantity is just insanely larger and the
more aura one has the more you can
regenerate which will likely result in
hisoka running dry first so it's
unfortunate but i think this opening
round is going to go to the royal guard
so next up into the bungee arena will be
nephipito and this this is going to be
probably controversial but i think that
hisoka stands a much better chance
against pito than he does against up
vito kind of has the worst of both
worlds going on firstly because unlike
up pito cannot regenerate damage i mean
that's not true actually they can but it
takes invoking dr blyth in order to do
so and when dr blyth is active it makes
pito stationery and stops them from
using men altogether both basic
invocations and then abilities so pito's
form of healing is rather ironically a
death sentence in this kind of matchup
so i guess what i'm getting at is that
if hisoka can land a devastating blow
then this fight is as good as his the
big question is can and if so how does
he go about accomplishing that a big
factor that pito has going for them that
yoopi did not is speed beto is certainly
the fastest of the royal guard but also
not impossibly fast high-level
combatants can respond to pito as proven
by kite when he was able to react
quickly enough to save gone and gone
sadly correctly noted afterwards that
kite would not have lost his arm if he
did not have two children to protect so
it's not like hisoka would be instantly
obliterated by sheer speed alone it's
definitely manageable at his level even
if he can't exactly match it one of
pito's bigger problems however is that
in addition to dr blyth their other nen
abilities are also pretty much dead
weight in this fight puppeteering for
example is pretty much entirely useless
even if pito is prepared with some sort
of undead puppet army they are
notoriously low quality and very simply
programmed blaspito can't even use it on
hisoka himself because it only works on
dead bodies however this does leave us
with turps core which is actually quite
useful as it buffs up pito's already
crazy physical abilities and that's what
this fight will probably come down to a
physical brawl and that is very much
hisoka's home field because the biggest
issue for pito is their inexperience
with nen pito's abilities do not
accurately reflect their almost godlike
aura quantity the abilities that poorly
constructed and based on whimsical
desires rather than raw need with the
exception of terp score which was
developed to help protect the king and
thus why it's the only truly useful one
but peter runs on this like weird blend
of animal instinct and human strategy
however neither of them are particularly
polished pito's instinct has repeatedly
led them into trap set by strategic
masters whilst pito's strategy was also
woefully insufficient against
world-class opponents all hisoka needs
to do is land one fatal hit which can
come in many forms or perhaps even
disable pito's limbs with bungee comb
meanwhile pito's task is much more
difficult because landing fatal blows on
hisoka with his post-mortem regeneration
is a very tough ask and i know that
you're all going to hate this but i'm
going to be a brave man and state my
opinion on the internet because i think
that hisoka can do it and the reason why
i know you're all going to hate my
conclusion is that in the poll we
conducted over 71 of all association
members gave this fight to pito which is
an absolute landslide and i get where
you're all coming from i just i think
that this is a surprisingly bad match
for pito pito's new abilities are next
to useless their speed is manageable
their damage is negatable meanwhile
hisoka is smarter right now he's weirdly
more durable and all he needs is one
opening to hit a win condition so fire
away in the comments because i am giving
this round to the clown which means that
we are in a one-one situation with
everything to play for in our final
match against shirapuff and i think that
poof is generally the most
underestimated of all of the royal guard
and that's probably because he's never
actually had a proper fight there was a
skirmish here and there but pouf's
clowning legacy in hunter hunter is that
he managed to avoid a lot of violence in
an arc filled almost exclusively with
non-stop violence that doesn't make him
any less formidable though in fact
speaking strictly mentally poof would be
by far hisoka's toughest opponent
because poof is something of a genius
prodigy he thinks not only about
physical strategy but also deeply
analyzes the psychology of his opponents
which is significantly enhanced by his
spiritual message hatsu he's someone who
much like crollo would be able to break
down everything that is hisoka and make
him much more predictable but the real
clincher here is that even if hisoka can
prevail in the mental struggle i still
don't think he has any actual win
condition shayapov's greatest strength
in this matchup is his effective
invulnerability in fact the hisoka
pouf's abilities are even more
challenging to deal with than yupi's
body morphing in regeneration because
should hisoka manage to hit or even
capture poof in a bungee [ __ ] trap then
all pouf needs to do is use beelzebub to
split into thousands of nanopuffs and
hisoka really has no way of dealing with
them in order to snuff out all of these
little dude bras you'd need a more area
of effect style of attack like killer
was electricity for example however he
soaked over he's not an aoe kind of guy
he's definitely geared towards
one-on-one combat because that's what
interests him at the same time though
pouf kind of demonstrably lacks the
ability to harm hisoka like at all
weirdly enough we never actually got to
see any offensive action from puff so
it's hard to judge how well he could
damage hisoka but again even if he does
that their bungee gum is going to easily
regenerate our magicians it's a really
odd fight to think about in the end my
prediction is that hisoka would become
flaccid and lose interest in both
because he's just not an interesting
opponent hoof doesn't really want to
fight ireland or his abilities geared to
do so and it seems more likely that
hisoka would just wander off elsewhere
to seek new thrill rather than try to
pursue this so personally i think this
fight would be a bit of an anticlimactic
stalemate however you all think quite
differently because for the first and
only time in this bowl the association
has deemed that hisoka would be
victorious against a royal guard member
with over 47 percent of the vote it was
quite tight when compared to european
pito but an intriguing result
nonetheless and maybe it could happen
very maybe but hisoka i just can't see
him ever being able to truly defeat poof
which from my perspective leads us with
a 1-1-1 the royal guards win with yupi
they lose with pito and conduct a bit of
a pointless exercise with boof leading
to a really sad draw however according
to the new world association the royal
guard would have won with both yupi and
pito emerging victorious whilst pouf is
sadly defeated just as you should sadly
defeat this next video by watching it
because there's always more to learn
explore and experience with this
wonderful series so i look forward to
seeing you there